Uh,
I will leave it to their choice.
I'm gonna say,
what is your objective in world,
uh,
in life?
What do you want to do?
Eh,
you want to make money,
enjoy yourself,
have all the things that,
uh,
needed for your enjoyment,
house,
cars,
a yacht or whatever.
Um,
this is one way.
This is your success or you want to
contribute.
You want to have a meaningful
interaction with the rest of the world
that,
uh,
they feel that a,
you are being useful to the planet and
are useful to your fellow human being.
So if you want to make a mark on this
planet,
if you want to be admired,
if you want to be respected for what you
have done,
what your cap capability or creativity
or intelligence has brought to this
world reduces some of the problems or
even remove some of the problems,
uh,
then social business will be one way
that you can adjust that.
Uh,
all you want to be a big rich person who
want to be on the top list of richest
man in the world or richest woman in the
world.
That's your choice.
But these are the two choices you have
to make a whatever way you want to go
about it.
These are the options you have.
You can mix both of them.
If you're successful,
you can make money the same time,
uh,
contribute to the world by using that
money in social justice.